DONORS ARE ENDORSING,
THINK  AATCHING ALL OF
TR PRESIDENT S LATEST CAMPAN
TOUGR GOING THANIS
AS JUST .
E LYY IN
>> Repor T COUNTY,EXAS IS G CHA.
PRONOUNCED MIAMI.
AL PRONOUNCE IASR DONALDTRUMP. 0
OP 95% OF THE VOTE IN 2016 AND
NATION.
T IS TRUMPISM ONCK
CONTINUED CC THINK I T ON.S IS
PRESIDENT AND THERE IS A NOTABT
E RETIRED AN ORANCH
THE COUNTY.VERYON
VIEWED SAY THED FOR DONALD
AN REPUBLICAN PRESIDENTIAL
DO YOU KNOW
WHO YOU WOULD VO FOR PROY DeSAN.
LY PENCE BUT DEFINITELY
NOT TRUM Reporter: AND YOUR HUS
THAT MANNALD TRUMP
VOTERS HERE ARE Y FOR A
DIFFEREN.NID KKHALEY.
>> Reporter: HOM LIKE HER VIEWS
>> Reporter: IF U E
TODAY WHO WOULYO?
>>
ND IS INSOLI
THE OIBU SO COLLES DOESNI WARNSY
POL INTRUDER HE IS NOTG 911.
S FE LONERTIBLICAN NOT SHY ABOU
CRITICIZING THE MAN
TWICE.
>> HSHADY THINGS
I'M NOT REAL FOND OFIGHT NOW.
I'LL IOMETHING
ELSE BETTEter: WKITHINGS?
A DOCUMEN STUFF
ML OF
I THINK HE'S HIDDE
STUFF.
WE DON'T NEED THAT IN OUUNEVERY
>> Reporter: RICK McDOWELL HUNT
SUPPORTER IN ONE OF OU
VISITS BUT H I
AS HE OR RONeSANTIS.
KES LOYAL
PEOPLE.
WHY AREN'T YOU LO  AGAIN?
>> I THINK HIS TIME IS OVER.H B
STILHA RSS COUN GOING TO STAY LL
STAY WITH DONALD.
>> RepE
CONDUCTED HIMSELDU Y LIKE THEMO
D YOU WANT TESIDENT AND WHO VIC
PRESIDENT?
ELECTED MOREA LOT OF PEOPLE THAT
HATE.
>> VOTED FOR HIM ORIGINALLY TRU.
BECAUSE I WAREG
AGAINST HILLARY ANGAINSTBIDEN AT
MIGHT BE GOOR TH
BUT HE
THE COUNTRY.
>> Reporter:>>I DON'T THINK HE N
W
>>HE CITND INSURRECTION.
AND THE COMMENTS H NOTRO RAGREE
YOUR WIFE?
A PERCE SIR.
>> GARIN
COUNTY, TAS
>> Reporter: THE ANSWER IS NAND.
TRUMGANDICATION THEY N
WOULD GO THAT A POINTESW
N THE  BEEN
IN THEIRAMILY FO THA
HUNDD I ASKED THEM SPECIFICALLY
FOR
REPUD TRUM